[Music]
finishing should go Sky High
okay
wow that stuff's happening
it's Heaven okay
[Music]
hi everybody I'm Zoe Saldana Worthington
and this is snack Wars for lead Bible so
why are we doing um Australia and why
are we doing the us today
um because I'm Australian
foreign
's Australian and we're gonna see which
of our snacks are the best obviously
so we're gonna see
oh my God this is the famous
veggie mic which is just it's B complex
on a spread right yeah this is the idea
you gotta go you go oh okay I've done it
I grew up on that
or
[Laughter]
good what is this
what is it Sam it's just a vegetable
extract
it's healthy no I know it is I've heard
that Vegemite has always been like a
very healthy thing that Australians give
to their kids but I'm so sorry for all
the children in Australia
now this peanut butter and jelly
sandwich
you don't like this it's tough yeah I
like boys
you did that
oh
that was Heaven I think they both get a
point okay
done deal oh it's cool yes you eat that
you'll be eating it for hours it just
gets stuck in your teeth and then you
can I tell you how much I love like that
kind of candy you can get white ones of
these called milcos were way better
my kids are obsessed with these
they're the best
it's good
it's so good the whole family
[Music]
well I have these in my closet guys I
keep them in every other drawer and
it'll last me a year they are very solid
yeah you can get even more sour than
these yeah but here's the things
this is a good trip from the dark web
if you go if you go on a date with
someone that you are really really
interested in and you go watch a really
sad movie you can have sour patch
and every time they look at you you look
like you're really into the story
no no don't tip these are awesome they
win
[Music]
[Laughter]
now drink it
no thank you listening should go Sky
High oh God Sam Sam okay
um this is definitely something that my
my mother never allowed us to drink when
we were growing up so
um I'll give the point to Australia yeah
I'll tell you I have a little sip of
that this stuff here they have a thing
in Australia called Iron Man right and
the ad for this was always some guy
kayaking down a waterfall or you know
carrying a big animal on his back like
it was the ultimate drink so as a guy
you you have you're the solo man he was
called you need to do like these crazy
adventures and that was the
advertisement and you're meant to slam
it down fast and then crush the can
against your head
a red ball or something right yeah but
not a rebel it wasn't an energy drink it
was pre-energy drinks really
wow that stuff's heaven
it's happened
I think no thank you I think I think
Australia takes the point for sure then
okay
[Laughter]
kill me let me just burp him away from
everybody
foreign
it's the way it shatters that matters
really that's how you do it that's how I
do it okay
what's in it honeycomb
evaporated honey
this is like this is like what your
dentist tells you know
okay all right Australia
like that
it's I I don't hate it
okay but um that can break someone's
tooth
love Reese's Pieces
love them
these are the mini ones too
so I think we know who wins in this one
right well I don't know about it
do you like
um
I much prefer a chiquito
this is like a well it's another
Australian candy chiquitos I like violet
crumbles are of the same family yeah
down
what they are they're like crocodile
Dundas
well you know Crunchies yeah yeah yeah
the crunchy a violet crumble is if you
put the crunchy out in the sun
oh no there's something in a like in a
freezer because it's harder the sun
would melt the thing what am I talking
about so you put it in the freezer but
that's what it is a harder version of a
crunchy yeah oh wow I mean it's not I
don't hate it so that's a point yeah go
Australia
for this game Australia one
[Music]
it's like this don't do it don't do it
oh
got to do it do it do it
you're like that I got you
oh God spit it out spit it out
wow oh God so much pride there's no
cheese in this